hello everyone
welcome to rational science
uh
i thought for a moment i was cut off
welcome to rational science uh directly
from frankfurt germany
and uh the only site on the internet
that does
science everybody else does
particles and you cannot explain
a single phenomenon of nature invisible
and
intangible phenomenon of nature
with particles in a rational manner
and science is about
rationality rational explanations
so yeah this is the only site that does
science
and today we're going to talk about uh
an uninvited guest and his name is
god but he's not the god of
the bible is the god of quantum
mechanics
he's the god of uh really of
mathematical physics
specifically of math of quantum
mechanics
and the other day we covered god the god
of christianity primarily and
we found out that you know he he he's
there
right i mean religion
claims that god is eternal that he had
no maker
and i really have no problem with that
you know
i can accept that hypothesis the problem
i have with
with god with eternal god
is not him it's how he created
something from nothing how he created
matter
from total void total nothingness from
space from vacuum
that that's uh i can't find the spec
or the instructions or the process in
the bible
that's the problem i have with with the
notion
of an eternal god uh you know how he
created
the first bit of matter and
quantum mechanics together with general
relativity and the rest of mathematical
physics
has a similar problem because they get
rid of god altogether
but they do believe and propose and
spread
that matter came into existence
i guess you can cut from nothing
whatever nothing is because
when you put them you you put the uh
mathematicians against the ropes and
begin to pummel them and you say well
where did
the first bit of matter come into
existence
uh they say it's an unscientific
question
and they put it off like that they say
it's like asking what's north of the
north pole or who knows who
what and the reason they say that is
that um
or the the way they justify it is by
saying they have no way of testing that
hypothesis
okay so in either case we have to
concede
or grant as a starting point not from
frame one
but for frame two frame one in one case
we already have god
and the other one we have something and
call it whatever you want
and from that point on we have the big
bang explosion
and everything that we have see today
so what we're going to look at today is
is that
process how this god
of quantum mechanics uh
grew into adulthood i i think she's a
teenager
today because i mean i would think that
god has
the god of mathematics right has a long
life ahead of him
uh i would say maybe trillions of years
assuming that's the case well he's in
him he's in his
infancy now okay and today we're going
to look at the process
not of how he began because you know
they concede that they say
he already started or he was there or
whatever and we're gonna look at how he
grew up
okay and so let's look at these two
gods the one from christianity compare
them against the one from mathematical
physics
and see if there if there are any
differences
in what those differences are if any
okay here it is okay uh the god of the
bible says in the beginning god created
the heaven and the earth
okay so he was already around okay and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
okay and in the case of quantum uh the
quantum bible the ancient
quantum bible that is is at least or
close to a hundred years old uh it says
in the beginning there was nothing
okay and we're going to try to find out
what this nothing is
part of it has to do with that and but
they say that
there was no god in a christian sense or
in the old testament
sense that there was a god around to do
any of this so they get rid of god
altogether
in fact all these people claim that they
are atheists that they don't
believe in the existence of god
and so they try to do what they say what
they call
scientifically okay
so we're going to do this scientifically
okay okay
let's uh go to step number two uh we get
the first
frames or frame
of the movie of the universal movie and
here's the two versions
uh in the case of christianity that you
read that
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
okay so there were waters we don't know
where those came from and god said let
there be light
and there was light okay and god saw the
light
that it was good and god divided the
light from the darkness in other words
he created
the day from the night because uh in the
day you have this
sunny day in other words you have a sun
you have clouds you have a blue sky
and at night it's like dark and uh
little stars are out there so it's a
little different okay so
that's i guess what they're referring to
in the case of uh
mathematical physics we have the quantum
formed that's where it starts says and
the quantum foam
moved upon the face of the false vacuum
okay and the equation said let e equals
mc square then there was
energy and the mathematician saw the
energy that it was scientific
and then they equated energy with space
that's essentially their version of
creation
in a nutshell okay according to
mathematical physics
space is a physical object made of
particles
in other words uh it's the ether
the same thing we've had for the last
3000 years
ether bunch of particles uh
and the only issue there is whether all
these bunch of particles
are space the word space refers to all
these bunch of particles
or whether the particles are contained
within a container called
space and those are two different
notions of the ether one is a bunch of
particles and you wonder what
separates one particle from the other
you know how you can distinguish them
and
unless there's something in between them
okay and that formed that whole body
form
space vacuum whatever you want to call
it the ether
is space in that case and in the other
case it's uh
these particles that are within
something called
space which is i guess some kind of
container that has
a border of a fence
and the only issue there also is you
know uh
what's outside of the fence what gives
shape to that container
called space so these things are the
ones that these people have yet to
justify and somehow uh rationalize for
us
okay so this is where we're at okay so
what happens next well
let's look at the one version here this
is the christian version
it says god is assumed to be eternal
that's fine we'll concede that god
creates heaven in the earth there we
have a problem because now he's creating
something from nothing
and we don't know how he did that okay
but here's the issue the issue
because this is where the difference is
going to be with mathematical physics
okay so pay attention to this it's the
timing
okay the bible if you go by the bible
literal reading of the bible no reason
to
interpret anything here i'm sure god
would not like
us to be confused there's a supreme
being
i think if if he wrote the bible if he's
the author as
is said out there he would have written
the bible in such a way that everybody
understands the same thing
and the way i look at it if uh we're all
confused and we don't cannot explain
this guy interprets one thing the other
guy interprets something else
we have to think that it's the devil
who's sticking his tail
in there right confusing people that's
my
logic for that okay anyways here it is
uh what does god do on the first day
he creates light okay and separates
night from the second day
he creates the firmament the heaven the
sky and
what does he do that for apparently to
separate the waters
okay the water from the ocean from the
from the sky i guess
okay third day we have dry land for the
first time you know we can put our feet
on something okay we have
dry land seas and he creates the plants
okay uh fourth day we have the sun the
moon and the stars you finally
sprinkle all these little dots out there
in the sky who knows for what reason
i guess for our enjoyment so we would
not see a dark
uh sky all day long and you know we
would look up there and see all these
little lights and hello enter see how
nice
okay um fifth day he creates the fishes
and the birds so we've got something
inside the water we have something in
the air okay
and finally he thinks about populating
the earth we have terrestrial animals
and man
okay we finally came in there and i
guess we were the last ones
to be created you know and uh you wonder
why
and then uh seventh day uh god dressed
it and
my only issue there is why did god need
to rest
i mean he's all powerful and all he's
got to do is say
abracadabra voila you know
hocus pocus whatever the
magic incantation is and uh
and you know it would not even take a
day it would take
one second a split second and whatever
he creates
it's there now if you took a full day
you would think there's some kind of
process
some mechanism some specification
of how to do this okay it'd be nice you
know it would have been nice if he would
have written that down
you know in the bible so we knew what
the process was
for creating these things but again if
he did it by hocus pocus magic whatever
i don't know why he needed to rest i
think the only reason he would need to
rest
is if he's tired and if he's tired is
because it took him
some kind of effort physical effort to
create these things
throughout the whole day and yeah again
it'd be nice to know what the process
was
okay but we don't have that information
uh the bible doesn't tell us
and that was a big omission i think okay
okay so how does quantum mechanics do it
um
let's put it over here so we can pair it
side by side
okay and you have this chronology which
i'm going to go
over in a minute but i want you to look
at something i want you to look at the
timing the timing is totally different
and unlike uh
the one on the left that goes day by day
in other words it's
it's constant it uses a single
unit which is the 24-hour day i would
think
because i don't see why they would have
to call it a day if it's not a day
and you know you would think that that's
a full day especially when he created he
said you know separates night from day
he says that in there the bible says
that god
is telling us this uh if he separated
night from day
meaning a 24-hour human day you would
think each one of these took one human
day there's no reason to
think that that you have to interpret
these days as millions of years or
anything like that
on the other hand on the right side you
see something very
different the first few
phases took seconds actually
microseconds okay took a very very small
amount of time
from there they jumped to minutes from
there they jumped to
thousands of years to millions of years
into billions of years
so the chronology there is totally
exponential
okay the the one that uh quantum
mechanics
comes up with uh to explain the origin
of the universe right okay
uh so let me get back in here
okay uh the other thing i want you to
see is this
um
this is these are the phases the epochs
for each one of the two eras there's two
eras one is the radiation era
that and again we're talking about right
after the big bang because
we don't know what happened at that
first frame at frame number one where
the big bang uh was getting
ready to explode okay so we don't know
what happened there and they don't have
an
answer for that and they say it's
outside of the
bounds of science etc etc okay fine so
all we can do is look at
from frame number two onwards okay and
this is what you get you get
two stages or
epochs or eras periods whatever you want
to call them
one is the radiation era and it consists
of all these
epochs planck the grand unified
okay the which is the grand unified
theory
okay remember they're trying to unite
forces okay
and that's what they're going to talk
about there then they have the
inflationary period
where this thing expands uh apparently
exponentially again
electroweak the quark the hadron or
hadron
pronounced differently in different
parts of the world
which is when you get into the neutrons
and protons okay
then suddenly you jumped into the
leptons and the nuclear
uh era on the other side you get um
see this the ones on the left are going
to be in seconds and
maybe you could call it even a minute
when you get on the right-hand side the
matter area now you get into
uh thousands millions and billions of
years
and we get the atomic epoch the galactic
and the stellar
okay so that's in a nutshell uh
what they propose okay what the
mathematicians propose
and here's a um i guess you could say
a a quick synopsis of this so that you
can see what i'm going to cover here
and how they view this okay um these are
the different eras
okay and the different epochs within
each era
okay here's the matter era here
divide into atomic galactic and stellar
um epochs and the first part which is
the radiation era
is separated by these uh planck
the grand unification or unified right
the inflationary period which is the
world expense
exponentially and then you go to these
the
quarks the hadron and lepton and the
nuclear okay
so that's essentially um how
mathematical physics
sees the uh evolution of the universe
and again i would have to suspect that
father universe
it's not so much father maybe he's a
teenager by now okay
so i don't know how mature he is okay
okay here's the first era known as the
plank era which is
uh microseconds
i mean you're talking about what is it
10 to the minus 43 i think
uh seconds right after big bang so it's
uh you don't even
have time to measure because it's
already gone okay so that's how fast
this was it was just
blip it was it came and went
okay and here it is okay and this is
uh yes again the blank era
the plank epoch okay it says the planck
epic what does it consist of it's no
matter
existed you know uh in the universe at
this point in time okay
and um only energy whatever energy is
again they use this word energy as a
substitute i call it the word spirit
because they claim there's no real
matter no particles i guess you could
say because even if you have a single
particle
you would think that's matter but they
said no
all we have at this point in time are
energy
and the ancestor of the four forces
okay and now they're not talking about
the four horses of the apocalypse
they're talking about four forces of
quantum mechanics
and we have a problem here a real
problem because uh
i can only imagine two forms of contact
and
which we call forces one is pulling one
is push
that's it and in fact if you go into
quantum you find
uh the two push forces one is the photon
the electromag magnetic force
and the other one is the weak force okay
and those are the
push forces because they are outward
going
uh they go out of the atom
and then you have the two pull forces
one is gravity gravity
which they have never figured out and
the other one is the gluon which holds
you know the quarks together inside the
nucleus of the atom
so we have two push forces two pull
forces but they claim to have four
forces
uh so you figure it out okay so uh the
issue is
right now we have no particles matter
they have what they have energy and they
have
forces but it turns out when you go into
quantum
they mediate all forces with particles
they say the forces are
particles because what is the
electromagnetic force well that's the
photon
it's a little ball supposedly that
mediates
light and electromagnetic phenomena such
as
magnetism so so you have a particle
anyways
and what is uh the weak force it's a
particle the w's and z's
are particles what is the gravity time
well
it's the mediator of gravity which is a
force but
what is the mediator the graviton what
is the gluon
allegedly another particle that mediates
the strong force
so they're all particles and a particle
is matter
but they're claiming there's no matter
in this period this
era or this epoch the planck
uh epoch um all you have is forces
and what are forces particles what are
particles matter
so they have a circular argument in
other words and why because they've
never defined their terms
they're suggesting that they're talking
about particles but when you say well
are you talking about really particles
like
you know little balls no no we're
talking about numbers
we're talking about quantities we're
talking about amounts and units and
that kind of stuff it's all math it's
got nothing at all to do with particles
meaning it's got nothing to do with
physics
so all they're doing is describing uh
this
epoch mathematically and what happens
uh according to them inside the labs
at such and such temperatures you create
certain effects and that's what they
extrapolated to the beginning of the
universe
okay so this is what how they came up
with all this stuff
okay at the end of this epoch uh gravity
split away
from the super force the super force is
the four forces together okay
and so you have gravity in there you
have gluon in there
you have the weak force and you have the
electromagnetic force they're all
in this so-called super force
okay so we have super force in there
gravity
the graviton i guess is gonna fly away
this
force is gonna fly away
you know it doesn't make any sense to me
i mean how do you say well i have
push and pull together in a super force
and i'm gonna pull or or expel
the pull force out of there what sense
does that possibly make
that you're going to uh expel or
or embed get rid of
the uh the pull one of the one of the
two forces in this case right the pull
force you're gonna kick it out and
you're gonna stay
only with another force in there this is
what they claim happened
in the plank era they said they had four
forces one of them in this case
gravitational force was kicked out of
the club
no longer belongs to the club and now
you have the other three forces keep in
mind what forces you got in there you
have
the strong force okay which is the gluon
particle no matter
you have the uh because we're not in the
matter age yet
uh you have the electromagnetic force
the photon a particle which is not
matter i guess
and you have the weak force the w's and
z's
which are particles which are also not
matter okay
we have these string forces still in
there we kicked out the rabbiton
or the gravity force
okay uh what's next we have the gut
here it is the gut the grand unified
theory okay
and what is that well uh grand unified
uh has
um or they're trying to get this this
equation that represents the grand
unified theory meaning
you have the electromagnetic force the
weak force and the
strong force together and what happens
here they're going to kick out
the strong force they're going to kick
it out of the club
and by doing so they kicked out the two
pull forces they kicked out gravity in
the previous uh
episode now now they're going to kick
out
the remaining pull force the gluon force
the strong force okay
and so that's what this epoch deals with
the kicking out of this
uh force anyway you want to
interpret kicking out of force okay if
that makes any sense to
you and so out of the three forces now
we have two forces
in there which are the electromagnetic
force and the weak force the w's and z's
and the photon
okay which are not particles or
which are particles but which are uh
not matter somehow you gotta try to
explain that okay or
to yourself okay okay what's the next
step
well now we got to keep separate these
two forces okay
so we got to separate the
electromagnetic
from the weak force okay and again i
don't know how to illustrate a force i
put it as
a little bit of smoke there i mean i
hope you don't hold it against me i have
no other way of
knowing what a force looks like okay so
if you know
please let me know okay uh because
i'm totally ignorant i confess i'm
totally ignorant in these matters
so i had to put some smoke some
different smoke between
weak force and uh the electromagnetic
force please forgive me
okay and yeah this is when the
electromagnetic
force separates from the weak force okay
in this
stage now remember all these are
microseconds you're talking about
infinitesimal part of a second that's
how fast this was
you know that's how it went didn't even
give you time to breathe
and they were already separated okay
keep that in mind it's a very swift
process
and where did they get that uh all these
things they got them from equations they
do these calculations
uh from what they observe in the lab and
they say look at such and such
temperature and at such and such speeds
uh this is what happens and they
interpret that
as a separation of forces they
extrapolate this to the beginning of the
universe and they say
this is what must have happened
you know uh what is it 13.7 billion
years ago
okay so that's how they come up with all
this stuff uh it's all equations
it's got nothing to do with you trying
to visualize
how a force separates from another force
it's got to do with equations they say
at this
temperature this is what would have
happened okay so all calculations
nothing more than that
okay what's the next step uh we have the
this uh step here it's uh
what is it the electro weak and uh
i know this is the one i just had for
let me go with the next one here
where is it the quark one
okay so now we're in the quark gauge
what is a quark
well you have three quarks and they form
part
of one of the uh
members of the nucleus of the atom
okay so you have uh what what are called
nucleons
okay you have things like neutrons you
have things like
protons and each one of these is made of
three
quarks in one case two downs and one up
the other one two ups and one down
not important at all okay they have
these three
quarks that make up the atom and
this is the age when these quarks are
made okay
so it says the universe is uh too hot
for indents for subatomic particles to
form so all you have
so far are just these quarks and they're
running around
running around where i suppose in space
because each quark is
contoured by space what what is the
backdrop to each one of those particles
that's what you got to ask
and the problem here is that space is
made out of particles according to
quantum mechanics
so we have particles inside particles
particles inside the ether as i said
originally okay the space of quantum
mechanics
and the space of general relativity as
well
are made of particles okay
so so you don't have absolutely nothing
what you have is
a sandbox as i call it they don't see it
as a sandbot they like to see it as a
beehive
all these little bees running around
um i don't know uh you figure out if
it's a sandbox or a beehive
a bunch of bees moving around you would
need for them to be
live otherwise you would think that
they're talking about a sandbox and if
you have a sandbox you don't have much
motion there
other than perhaps gravitational motion
whatever gravity is
okay so keep in mind all this stuff they
would not be able to explain a lot of
this stuff
um because if they have a sandbox
uh you know how does one particle push
another one over and do something with
it
create pressure or whatever you want to
call it you you cannot
explain uh motion and if you have
beehives well
the particles have to be alive because a
beehive you know a bunch of bees
i think they're alive they're you know
flapping their wings
okay okay uh what comes next
uh the hadron era or hadron era okay
and what happens here this is also a
little bit magical so
you know hold on to your seat here okay
hadron uh the universe is
cools down a little bit okay this allows
quarks
to bind together and form protons and
neutrons
okay so we're gonna form protons and
neutrons simply because the
temperature dropped okay
and one of the problems here is that
you're you're going to form like a
nucleus of the atom okay
and they're gonna show how this ends up
uh
creating not hydrogen which is the
number one element they're gonna start
with helium
they're gonna form helium but it's going
to be a helium atom
that does not have electrons it just has
the nucleus
okay so keep this in mind they're going
to form
a helium helium atom okay
which consists of four nucleons in other
words two protons and
two neutrons helium atom is not one and
one it's two and two
you would have to have two electrons to
counterbalance the
two positive protons but there are no
electrons all you have
is just two protons and two neutrons
okay and they call that i guess a helium
atom an ionized helium atom
okay okay so this is this is uh
you got to keep all this stuff in mind
because there are there are a lot of
things that are not explained by quantum
mechanics and all this they just say
well
this is what the equations show and this
is what the kind of temperatures you
would need to create this
this result that's how they handle this
okay
okay here we have um the next era
the lepton and nuclear we'll put them
together here
lepton and nuclear uh
protons and neutrons form
are fused and uh
form a again a
nucleus a nucleus they form
each one of these is a nucleon and when
they get together they form the nucleus
okay and that's when the helium comes
into being
i put the electrons in there so that
they wouldn't look so bad
uh so ignorant uh
because as far as i know helium requires
two electrons to
for it to be helium otherwise all you
have is two protons and two neutrons
is that just that alone is that a helium
atom
and you wonder also about hold it
why doesn't hydrogen come first before
helium
because see uh the explanation they have
for how a star works let me get this guy
out of here uh here
the explanation they have for how helium
is formed
they say it's formed in the sun and
start inside a star
and that's okay i have no problem with
that in fact i like that theory
quite a bit and they say you take four
you have to have four four hydrogen
atoms
you smash them together okay
and with those four you create a helium
atom why because you have to have four
nucleons two protons
and two neutrons right
and because you have two protons you
only have two positive charges you
counter balance that with two electrons
which are the two
negative charges okay so
so okay in general terms uh
i i think it's reasonable the question
is why would
god create the god of quantum create
helium before he created hydrogen if
we're trying to figure out
how hydrogen came into being and from
there eventually to stars and then smash
them into helium
because you can understand how helium is
formed in the stars
once you have hydrogen but these people
started
helium and worked their way towards
hydrogen it's like you know god invented
helium before you invented hydrogen
so you figure that out i mean i think it
was easier to form
hydrogen and helium all you need is one
proton one electron
you you would think that's easier right
why would
god take the trouble of forming helium
before he formed hydrogen
is is beyond my understanding
okay what is a lepton just in case here
uh
because we're talking about leptons and
this also is a can of worms i'm not
gonna go in detail over but i just want
you to understand
what we're dealing with here left down
is an elementary
particle okay of half integer
spin spin half okay that does not
undergo strong interactions
i don't know what uh what they're
talking about what do you mean half
spin you know when i spin the top the
whole top spins
i guess if it spins halfway you stop it
or stop the movie or it falls or
whatever and you say well that was a
half spin
i mean how else are you going to
understand it or maybe it's half a top
spinning full spin i mean i don't know i
don't know how to interpret the
half spin and the answer is that
they never define the word spin they
have no idea what it means in physical
terms spin is not what spin
means to a normal human being when you
spin a top you say that's spinning
everybody understands that everybody
understands when you say the earth spins
everybody understands that half spin
minus half minus one spins nobody
understands that at all
in fact the people who propose it don't
understand it it's just a mathematical
uh device
invention concoction they say
uh yeah it's a half spin so what do you
mean by spin
they don't know but whenever they want
to explain like how a magnet attracts
another
they insinuate that you know the
electrons are spinning on both
magnets and that's why they attract the
two magnets attract each other because
the electrons are spinning
like a top in both magnets
so they use these words uh
they invent the word spin and they say
well you know what i mean by spin don't
you yeah yeah i know what you mean by
spin well
okay that's how a magnet attracts
another uh
what do you really mean by spin oh we
don't know
especially when they come with half spin
and -1
spins and zero spins you know i mean
what is a zero spin so so
again you can't picture this you cannot
visualize what they're
talking about all you can do is use it
use the term that they invented and they
say well it's a mathematical contraption
and you got to go to university
understand what spin means
but when they want to give you the the
physical interpretation they use spin as
if it were the spinning of a top
so they they have these dualities which
they get away with murder
uh because when people don't understand
math they don't care about math they
want to know
you know how a magnet attracts another
the guy says well the electrons are
spinning in the same way
and you're visualizing spin what spin
means to you
that the electrons are really spinning
you say okay i more or less understand
that
but when you put them against the wall
and you say well what do you really mean
by spin they don't know
they say well no it's not the spin of a
top we we have no idea
so this this is the issue the issues
they have no explanations whatsoever but
they use these words
okay they use these words like positive
and negative what do you mean by
positive or negative oh we don't know
these are all mathematical terms has
nothing at all whatsoever to do with
physical interpretations which is what
the normal
average human being out there on the
street wants to know wants to understand
okay and there's two main classes of
leptons
exist uh charged leptons also known as
electron like leptons
and neutral leptons better known as
neutrinos okay
so uh yeah this is what the leptons are
and then
you figure it out these are just labels
names that they've invented we have no
idea what what they're talking about
back they they can't draw a single
electron they say they filmed an
electron swedes did a few years ago they
they came on the news you say okay
what's a
what's an electron look like they say
well we filmed it
and then they can't tell you what an
atom looks like
i mean you filmed an electron and you
filmed
or or or took uh an image
of gluons holding quarks together
because they
what they have is they smash these uh
nucleons one against the other ions
against ions
and they look at the explosion say that
that's a gluon that's a quark okay so
so here they have these traces of gluons
and quarks
they have the the width of the trace
through the gas meaning that they know
how what the diameter of that gluon is
or of that quark
and that's inside a nucleon which is
inside the
nucleus of the atom and they can see
these little
particles or they image them and then
you ask them what does an
atom look like which is a monster
compared to all these and they say oh we
don't know
they can't draw an atom because if they
draw the planetary
atom with a little ball you know made of
three quarks
uh mediated by gluons and they have this
electron going around
you say well what keeps the electron
bound to the
nucleus they can't answer that question
they can't tell you
physically what keeps it bound to the
elect
to the nucleus why doesn't the electron
fly away wasn't fall
to the nucleus so that's these are the
questions they can't answer and those
are the questions you should harp
upon you should ask those questions to
all these
uh mechanic quantum mechanics who
claim that they have a phd and that they
know a lot okay
tell me why the electron doesn't fly
away why does it fall inside the nucleus
what physically prevents it from flying
away what physically prevents it from
falling
inside the nucleus that's what they got
to answer and if they tell you field you
say field's not a physical object
can't use the word field to explain that
okay okay what's the next era well now
we start with the matter area now we
move
for fast forward thousands of years
okay so here it is this is the
first stage of the matter uh era
and it's the atomic um what is it phase
or
uh was it
the epoch the atomic epoch
okay and uh the universe cools okay so
we're
it's all about cooling i guess because
it spreads out and it's so cold out
there it's like
just moving inside a refrigerator i
don't know
uh the universe cools electrons attached
to nuclear for the first time now we
have
the atoms see so far we had the
helium atom but it was without electrons
now the electrons join the atom okay
and form atoms uh recombinations okay
and
uh the second element finally is formed
uh
hydrogen which is the first element on
the you know table of the elements
uh helium helium being number two
made of four hydrogen atoms essentially
okay what comes next well again we jump
uh from thousands to millions of years
now okay
and we enter the galactic era okay oh
wrong one
already me put this one down here
where i lose it give me a second here
okay here it is
uh this is the galactic era
okay and uh so what do we have here well
the formation of galaxies
but the formation of galaxies is a
little strange because
it's strange because we have no stars
okay all we have is whatever it's called
gas
so they say these islands of gas
those are galaxies because they are star
less
galaxies if you can imagine such a thing
so it's just a
some kind of cloud of gas that's
floating over here another one over
there and another one over there
these are i guess the proto galaxies
they're going to become
galaxies eventually okay this is where
stars are going to
form according to their evolution of the
universe the
chronology okay and uh yeah it's also
because of cooling
and uh these are the seedlings of
galaxies these uh
clouds of gas okay so that's how you
have to interpret this
and then we enter the final stage which
is the one i guess we live in today
okay and that's the stellar era or
epoch and what is this well it's the
formation of stars
and the formation of stars happens you
know again
you have these gases they form this what
is known as the
nebular hypothesis where you have these
spinning
uh masses of gas
and they collapse gravitationally they
start spinning
and collapsing until at some point
it nucleates and
at some point even further it
ignites because of the pressures of atom
against atom okay
and at some point that pressure creates
heat
gravitational heat gravitational
pressure and
at some point it ignites and suddenly
you have
radiation come out of there which is
what we receive from the sun
okay so this is this is the last phase
that's where we're at now is there going
to be
another phase after this uh maybe into
we covered what
we covered thousands of years we covered
millions of years billions of years i
guess the trillions of years is the next
stage
whatever that's going to be just uh
fizzling out into nothingness the future
of humanity i guess
is gone because all matter will simply
fly away so much from each other that it
uh turns into dust
that's i guess what you're supposed to
imagine that's the universe these people
are proposing that's the one they
believe in
okay okay um
so let's look at the comparisons of
quantum mechanics versus
christianity religion the bible uh
story are they that different or are
they different at all
and here you see it okay in one case you
have uh god is assumed to be eternal
god creates heaven and the earth okay
and we have all these different days
they're all days okay you would think
they're
typical 24-hour days there's no reason
to think otherwise that these represent
millions of years or anything like that
and on the right hand side you see the
differences you see the planck scale
you know that happened in so many zeros
that we cannot even imagine that
grand unified happens at minus 40 10 to
the minus 43 seconds
inflationary period minus 36
electro weak minus 32 and
quark and hadron uh goes all the way to
minus 12 minus six
okay so um until you get to the left
on you get to the first second so that's
how all this
proceeded that's how fast all this was
and
when you want to get into the nuclear
era well then you get above a minute a
minute and a half and so on
matter era well that's totally different
50 000 years 200 million years 303
billion years
so it's a little different than what you
see on the left
okay the the what's different is the
timing
one is exponential the other one is
constant or i would think it's constant
unless you know you want to interpret
that but i don't see why you would have
to interpret the bible the bible should
be
straightforward so that no so that
everybody interprets the same thing
so you should not have to interpret the
bible
okay but here you see these people and
they say well you know
the first few seconds and microseconds
everything happened very fast and
suddenly you get to this stage
where you produce the quarks and you
produce the hadrons
and then it takes thousands of years
until you get the first atoms
and from there well you get the galaxies
first which again
seems like uh counterintuitive
and then you get the stars and in the
case of atoms again you get the hydro
the helium atom before you get the
hydrogen atom
that's that's the chronology that these
people have
and again we have no idea where all this
stuff came from
uh they say it's an unscientific
question okay so
this is uh after so many calculations so
much math
all these phds from every university on
the planet
uh this is the scientific method that
they follow has
taken them to the these conclusions okay
so the question is whether
what they're following is a scientific
method if the
this scientific method that they follow
led them to such nonsense to
to come up with this evolution
of how uh forces converted into
particles particles
loose particles into formalized or
or organized particles such as atoms and
eventually into
stars and galaxies or galaxies and stars
i guess the other way around okay
so this is it uh this it's it's all
magic essentially the method of
mathematics i call it or the
mathematical method
we have equations observations no
definitions
for any word okay important they have
experiment they have predictions
what's the result of all this creation
of something from nothing
that's the first one and then we have
this nonsensical
surrealistic uh unexplained
process um a formation of matter
that's what we have today that's what we
ended up with after thousands of years
of doing math
experiments predictions etc etc etc
so the question is whether they're
following the right scientific method
maybe they're following
false gods okay maybe that's
what this is all about following false
gods you know you got to make sure you
follow the right god if you want to have
eternal life or whatever okay okay what
do we do
in in real science in science we let's
put it side by side so we can compare
these okay
this is how we do it in science we have
to define our terminology so that we
have
one idea of what we're talking about
and the first thing we have to define is
something and then we have to define
nothing and something is the opposite of
nothing they are
antonyms and so they have to be defined
in such a way as you keep them that way
that way you can use them consistently
and you can talk about whether something
came from nothing
and whether you can convert something
into nothing and so we say
something is that which has shape and
nothing that which doesn't have
shape see how easy it was all these
years
and so space is a synonym of nothing
and so is vacuum and something is
anything that has shape okay that which
has shape
so we have something that which has
shaped nothing that which doesn't have
shape now we can use them consistently
and we cannot imagine a mechanism where
you
convert something into nothing or vice
versa
taking nothing and converting it into
something with or without god
eternal or or in any other way
you cannot create you cannot imagine
creating something from nothing
meaning that nothing suddenly acquired
length width
and height and from one frame of the
movie to
the next one in other words in zero time
suddenly
something pops into being from nothing
that's known as magic
not even god can do that kind of magic
okay
and so anyone proposing creationism in
any way shape or form especially under
the guise of science
needs to explain the mechanism and
afterwards check himself into the near
psychiatric
ward okay that's the conclusion we
should reach
okay so let's compare what these people
have versus what we propose
okay here's the quantum version which is
essentially
the ether i can get this thing up there
give me a second here there he goes
that's quantum mechan that's the
universe of quantum mechanics particles
uh flying around okay and the question
is what's the black stuff
okay if you say space well you can't say
space because the white stuff
is space uh space is made of particles
in mathematical physics so the particles
that you see they're moving around
that space you got to tell me what the
black stuff
is that gives shape to each one of these
particles
the other one is why are they moving i
mean
it should be a sandbox and what you see
here is a bunch of bees
flying around okay moving and for them
they would have
to be alive okay flapping your wings or
whatever
so there's a lot of questions in the
version of quantum mechanics
what do we propose instead we propose
that matter was not created
we're saying that matter was always
there it's eternal our universe
i hate to use the word universe matter
was eternal and this is what it looks
like
here you get an idea if we can
get this thing here okay it's a single
thread universe there's a single thread
okay it's a closed loop thread and it's
gonna turn
into the rope rope is gonna go
all around the universe gonna
nucleate to what we call atoms and then
all these
atoms are going to be tied or bound to
each other by
the what we call the electromagnetic
rope that's all we have in the universe
that's how simple our universe is
no creation necessary it's just a single
thread that
weaves all around the universe okay
and uh it never happened and never as
far as i'm concerned i cannot imagine
how the single thread morphed
through a process into atoms
and ropes it's always been like that
there was no moment of creation matter
is eternal because we cannot imagine
atoms turning into space into empty
space or his
empty space that which doesn't have
shape suddenly acquiring shape and
turning into
the thread or atoms or the ropes
so no it's it's always been like that
it's always going to be like that when
we're gone
okay it's all you're gonna have all
these islands
uh galaxies and they're gonna have
stars and within those stars you're
going to have planets within those
planets uh
or near there you're going to have
asteroids and gases and so on
all of this is going to be made of atoms
all these atoms are going to be
connected by the
ropes that interconnect every any two
atoms
and the entire unit all that matter is
connected to
the matter in another galaxy as well
which is connected to the other one to
connect
the one into the other one the entire
matter in the universe
is interconnected did it come into being
did the rope somehow form atoms
or did the thread form ropes no it's
always been like that
and that's what people have trouble they
have no trouble imagining god being
eternal they say okay god's eternal he
had no mother no
umbilical cord uh but uh when you say
well the
the threads eternal too it's been there
in the form that we see today there's
been no change it's always been
galaxies and maybe the galaxies change a
little bit here and there and maybe they
collide and
form new galaxies or break apart that
that yeah that probably more than likely
happened
but uh other than that all you have is
just
atoms forming parts of uh matter
and that matter being stars and galaxies
and planets and whatever
that's our universe it's always been
like that's always going to be like that
right so in a nutshell that is
the universe we propose and we propose
it against what quantum mechanics
proposes which is also realistic
unimaginable
and if you come with general relativity
you know with the black holes
and dark matter and dark energy and big
bang well that's a total mess
so you figure it out and again here
we're not here to convince you because
that's not our purpose we're here to
propose uh two universes
okay it's up to you to choose which
whichever one appeals
better to you the important thing is to
understand it to understand what the
differences are and what the criticism
are against mathematical physics
and with that i'm going to go into
questions and comments okay so let's see
what people had to say we had a lot of
questions
related to especially what an object is
whether a square people don't know what
a square is still
whether square is an object a thing
and lots of questions there people
still are fighting with that issue so
let's start at the beginning and here uh
i i'd like to start with the golden
principle okay
golden principle physics okay and i'm
saying this is a non-negotiable
principle rational people should not
negotiate this one and agree or disagree
or anything along those lines
this is it you take it or leave it
otherwise you're in the rational
individual
okay and here it is the way i look at it
uh the golden principle
there it is you can't do physics without
an object
physics requires an object what would
there be
what what would be happening what would
there be to study what would there be to
analyze if there's nothing in the
universe no
object nothing if you have total empty
space or
whatever you imagine no shape whatsoever
what is moving so no you absolutely
need an object to do physics that's the
first issue
so first you got to define the word
object for the purposes of physics and
we define it as that which has shape
now you know what an object is for the
purposes of physics that which has shape
okay and those are the synonyms there
and i'd like to say
my my greatest contribution to science
the definition of the word object
destroys
all religions all religions die in the
definition
of the word object okay and we're going
to see that in a second here
we're going to see how a lot of
religions go down the drain
just with that definition okay all we
had to do
was define that word object so critical
to physics you can't do physics without
an object therefore you have to define
the word object
what does it mean what what does that
word mean for the purposes of physics
okay so now that we know what it means
that which has shape it's not that which
you can touch
it's not that which you can see it's not
that which exists
it's that which has shape
okay and i know people haven't just have
not listened to what i just said
because they're going to go back to
exist they're going to go back to touch
they're going to go back to c
which are the criteria we use in
ordinary speech in mathematical physics
everybody has this idea that's what you
can touch or see no
in physics it's that which has shape
and i'll tell you it takes two years for
people to really
for that to sink into people's minds
okay so i'm gonna harp on that so much
it's gonna hurt
now it's that which has shaped not that
which exists not that which you can
touch
not that which you can see okay and i'm
gonna harp on that it's gonna hurt
okay it's gonna make you lose your
religion whatever religion you have
you're gonna lose it right there in that
definition
okay let's find out how uh these people
begin to lose their religion losing my
religion
okay here it is uh first guy he says
bill's definition of object that which
has shape is too simplistic
well i'm sorry it's so simple and it's
been so
easy all these years uh
in fact good definitions are the
simplest ones especially when you're
defining the
foundations the simplest or most
basic words they have to be as simple as
possible
so i'm sorry it's too simple for you
maybe it's uh
below your mental state
and uh you're flying in those clouds up
there
yeah it is uh simplistic i'm sorry i'm
sorry it was so
easy so so kindergarten-ish okay let's
go with the second one
uh along the same lines all these folks
okay one fellow says the following he
says
uh to define an object that exists you
need at least three objects
an object cannot exist stand alone
and again uh failed to understand that
completely but
the argument is that until he defines
what an object is or what the word
exists means
we have no idea what he's talking about
you need to define those two words
in physics because physics is the
science of existence among
of objects and of existence consequently
i don't know if it's the same follow
these are
perhaps different vowels i don't
remember now consequently objects of
0 d 1 d 2 d 4 d 11 d 2 d 3 d as it are
not
really objects but concepts and cannot
exist
and you can see they always go back to
the word exist
they think that an object is that which
exists and they
talk about concepts but they have to
define the word concept
before they can do that they have to
define the word object and exist
and it says dimensions each of the
measures that determine the extent
of an object length within height or
death
wrong again of an object as as such has
always and as always and only 3d
again uh these people
[Laughter]
first of all they they mix depth with
height now
death is has is a vector depth is not
in a dimension okay and if you don't
understand that well you got a long ways
to go first you got to understand the
difference between vectors
dimensions and coordinates okay that's
the first issue
but uh the issue here is that you know
there
talks about dimensions of an object and
what does he go into again
3d why because he's talking about exist
it's like you need the word exist to
talk in physics and they always go back
to the word object and the word exists
so you can't live without those two
words in physics
but but they confuse the word
object where the word exists they think
they're synonyms and so
immediately when you say object you say
you know
a square has shape therefore by
definition
under rational science is an object they
say no no because it doesn't exist
[Laughter]
no no i know it doesn't exist because a
square is an object that doesn't exist
exists has nothing to do with the word
uh object with the definition of the
word
object and this is the whole issue the
issue they keep going back to exist
and until they define the word object
and the word exists we have no idea what
they're talking about they're just
running around in circles chasing their
tails
which is what all these so-called
philosophers like human camp did for
you know for hundreds of years
okay here's uh another fella along the
same lines says what
talking about angels the image of the
angel on a white background
is not an object what's got shape why
isn't it an object
the object called angel cannot be does
not exist
again goes back to the word exist it is
not real it is a concept
you see how they chase their tails
around they keep going around in circles
why because they never define the word
object in the word exist
you need to tell me what the word object
means before you even mention the word
in any sentence
and if you cannot define the word object
keep your mouth shut because you have
nothing to offer all you're doing is
chasing your tail around in circles
you're saying that an angel is not an
object or a square is not an object
because it doesn't exist
exists has nothing to do with the
definition of the word object
unless you can somehow define it in such
a way that you embody it within the
definition in
in that specification okay so again uh
these people are just chasing their tail
around they don't understand what the
argument is and they just go around in
circles forever and ever and ever and
ever
okay so uh here's a circular argument
here's a
here's what that what the problem is
with all these folks the reasoning
of the unreasonable object that which
has
uh which you can touch or see that's
what they think they're thinking
uh touch c and
then they say exist that which you can
touch and see
because what does exist well what i can
touch and see that's what they think
and so they essentially have equated
exist with object and object would exist
they think these two words are synonyms
which is the problem that we had with
david hume and emmanuel kant they also
confused one with the other uh
wittgenstein
uh russell enrand uh sartre they all
made the same error they confuse
exist with object with entity with thing
with uh
medium they thought they were synonyms
because they always thought that uh or
proposed
that an object is that which you can
touch or see exists is that which you
can touch and see and so there are
synonyms
that's that's our whole argument okay
and
here you have it on air uh is aaron
object
i mean it's made out of atoms right so
you would think that if
anything made out of atoms like real
atoms like the air in here oh if it's
made out of atoms it's got to be an
object
because you can touch it at least right
so but they say no air is not an object
because
uh i can't see it i guess and um and
neither is water even though you can see
and touch it
but why aren't these uh objects
according to them because they're
malleable
because they keep changing from moment
to moment second to second
through motion you know they they move
they they're not stable so they're not
objects so again we don't know what an
object is in their minds
and so that's the circular reasoning
they say object is c
touch an object is 3d
that's what they're thinking exists is
3d exist
is also what you can see in touch
therefore exist as an object
that's a circular reasoning and they
never get around out of that circle
they never get out of that circle
because they're using first
undefined terms they're using the
notions of ordinary speech
and until you define these two words
precisely and not move a single
letter out of that definition you don't
have a case
so first anyone who wants to try who
doesn't like
the fact that my definition destroys his
religion
define the word object do you find the
word exist before you do anything
before you even make a comment if you
don't have a definition
that you can defend for the word object
for the word exist
you have no case you can't even start
the discussion
because you have nothing to offer okay
so uh
that's it yeah you anyone who wants to
work on the words object and exist begin
by defining them and don't and please
don't go into the dictionary
you won't find the the definition in the
dictionary because no one has defined it
in the last 3000 years
no no one knew what an object is there's
not a single book of physics
that begins by defining the word object
and physics cannot be done without an
object and there's not a single book of
physics
on planet earth no textbook no treaties
none of those that um that tell you what
the
word exists means and physics is the
science of existence physics
explains or tries to figure out what
exists out there in the invisible
intangible world of mother nature
so you you need to define those two
words object and exist
think and exist okay and until you can
define them
you have no case okay another issue here
along the same lines all these people in
the same boat essentially okay
fellow says um says physics definition
of object oh the physics definition
let's hear it i want to see this
identifiable collection of matter
which may be constrained by an
identifiable boundary and may move as a
unit by translation or blah blah blah
blah blah dimensional space
okay what's the problem with it well
first of all he's proposing that this is
part of physics part of science he says
he got it out of a science book
well i doubt it because see when you
look it up
we find out where he got this ad there's
no scientific book because there's no
scientific book on planet earth
that defines the word object that's why
he's lying he's lying out of every
corner of his mouth
now here it is when you look it up you
find out where he got this from
he got it from the wikipedia okay and he
got it from an ordinary dictionary the
oxford dictionary perhaps says in common
usage
not in science in common usage a
physical object let me put it side by
side so you can see
that it's the same definition he put up
there okay here it is
uh common usage a physical object or
physical body or simply an object or
body is a collection of matter within a
defined continuous boundary in
three-dimensional space
so where did he get that he got it not
from a scientific dictionary he got it
from the wikipedia
and it turns out that the wikipedia has
a little note there saying this article
does not cite
any sources please help improve this
article by adding citations to reliable
sources
unsourced material may be challenged and
removed of course you're not going to
find
any reliable source for the word object
and certainly you won't find it in any
uh science dictionary or book of physics
they never define the word object and
you can't do physics without an object
that's how simple it is that's that
destroys all of mathematical physics
because it tells you that
these people are just doing equations
they're not doing explanations of
mechanisms okay okay and then
dictionary.com you find object anything
that is visible or tangible
again anything is a synonym of objects
so they're already starting with a
synonym
and then they say visible or tangible
for which in both cases you need
another object so you need an object to
define the word object
great and the same thing for the oxford
dictionary it says a material thing
material is already an object and thing
is also a synonym of object
that can be seen or touched same thing
you need another object to see or touch
so all these definitions are irrational
they are synonyms and when you use a
synonym to define a word that's no
definition at all all you have
is a circular so-called definition
meaning no definition at all
okay okay um
here's another comment on that um that i
put up there
okay uh again dictionary.com they use
the word anything
and the word thing okay and again
it's uh they have these loose
definitions like
in the second case there to which a a
person or matter
to which thought or action is directed
okay
and no that's not a an object for the
purposes of science or
physics okay a thing observed who does
the observing
another thing anything that we can think
of or talk about that's the subject of a
sentence that's not
a thing like a table okay we can talk
about motion
we can talk about orbit that does that
make
orbit a thing no not in physics orbit is
a verb
not a noun okay for the purposes of
physics
and so on down the line okay entity and
so on
uh they're all these are synonyms and
again they have the wrong definition
or the irrational definition because
they equate it with that which you can
see or touch
or that which exists none of which are
synonyms of the word object or
define an object okay
i think it's the same fellow he goes in
there and continues says
uh the physics definition of exist
let me put it over here and he says uh
the fact or state of
of living or having objective reality
well it turns out that um when you look
at reality
uh it's a synonym of exists so we have a
synonym again
and again he's proposing that this is a
scientific definition and you will not
find
a definition of the word exist in any
scientific dictionary so again he's uh
he's trying to
sell a whopper here he's trying to say i
got this out of a scientific dictionary
no no
no such monster because that definition
doesn't exist in any scientific
dictionary
no one in the last 3000 years in science
and so-called science or mathematical
physics
has discovered that you need to define
the word object in the word exist
okay and so uh when you look it up this
is what you find existence the fact
or state of living or having objective
reality
uh where did he get this he got it from
the oxford dictionary that's where he
got his definition because that's where
you find it
and the oxford dictionary is the normal
uh
dictionary of that everybody uses out
there
what is reality the state or quality of
having existence
okay that's according to oxford reality
according to wikipedia is the sum or
aggregate of all that
is real or existent so what is reality
it's a synonym of exist and you can't
use the word reality to define
the word exist and in existence the
ontological property of being what is
being
means the material or material existence
of a thing
again you can't use the word being real
really
reality any of those to define the word
exist because they are all
synonyms okay so anyone who uses those
words
it does not have a definition he's got a
circular definition
and that definition is circular because
they're using synonyms to try
to define so
you got to define reality or exist or
existence or
real in such a way that you do not use
the word being
you know any of those that you do not
use synonyms
that's the that's the challenge for you
that's the million dollar challenge
and if you can't do it you got nothing
to offer you have
your religion has been destroyed okay
so uh be aware okay here we go
uh another question another comment
file says uh there is no physics
definition i think it's the same file
there is no physics definition of
concept no kidding
in physics the standard definition is
accepted in other words
from ordinary speech from the ordinary
dictionary
what is a concept uh when you look it up
an abstract idea a general notion
and when you look at the word idea in
the word notion where we find
notion conception or idea of something
what is idea any conception a thought a
conception or notion they're all
synonyms
so we haven't learned anything about the
word concept we don't know what a
concept is because they're using
synonyms
ideas notion to define the word concept
okay oxford dictionary same thing but is
a concept an abstract idea
what is abstract existing in thought or
as an idea
what is an idea a thought what is the
thought and idea
we got it so all we did was uh chase our
tail around with all these definitions
from
mathematics essentially the so-called
science
but i like this uh last comment that
this guy made because it made me laugh
it really made my day
the guy says the following he says i
will never be using your definitions
it's a it's the kind of thing
that anyone ever said to me at least
this week
uh he's not he says you know you you
destroyed all my
religion i can't find a single
definition in the scientific dictionary
but i'm not going to use your definition
no matter what
[Laughter]
thank you i really appreciate that
okay let's move on another question
uh well let me analyze that a little bit
uh because here we have
a little bit of authority or so-called
authority from ayn rand okay she's a gal
that
tried to attack this problem and she
failed miserably
okay and so um
you ask me what is something and or what
is exist and she says something exists
which one perceives
no no no we don't need to perceive
anything this has nothing to do with
perception
but this is what ayn rand thought was
something that exists
one exists possessing consciousness no
we don't need consciousness to exist a
vegetable can exist
you know a person who is in the state of
kama
uh exists and you can say there's no
consciousness there in fact
we can remove the brain completely for a
few seconds that
person is or is completely dead you know
and uh has no consciousness but that
person exists there
that person is there and you say well
the body's there not the consciousness
well what is consciousness a concept do
concepts exist
we have concepts floating out here or
what is it what do you mean
by the consciousness exists or
uh perception exists or
any any um
concept how can you say that a concept
exists like love
how can you say love exists for this you
have to define the word
exist in such a way that it includes
concepts
and that's what ain could do and she
would never have been successful
because uh no you can't you can't talk
about the existence of any concept
intelligence you can't say intelligence
exists especially in the mathematical
community
now you can't use uh concepts and say
that they exist you can only use the
word
exist in the context of objects
okay and so here are
uh kind of responses to good ol aim
okay and uh
here it is to exist is to be something
yeah but that is not enough
in order to be exist you not only need
to be something
but you must have location that's the
difference between what enran
did and what rationality is uh you need
location it's got to be an object it's
got to have shape and then
in addition you got to have uh location
and to exist requires a something but to
be
something is not to exist there are some
things that don't exist
neither perception nor consciousness
have anything
to do with existence or entities okay
okay and let's move on uh with another
con comment that i want to make here
which is the key issue okay here's the
key issue
and it's that people uh all these
philosophers are so-called philosophers
why they failed
and i found a statement that summarizes
where they all went wrong and it's that
they separate
two kinds of existence one is the
existence with which
we should be concerned here is not just
any existent thing but human existence
okay so that where these people have
separated human existence
from the existence of a rock for example
and what what do we mean by human
existence well we're talking about
consciousness about
thinking about mind okay that's where
the problem comes in
there is thus an important difference
between distinctively human existence
and
anything else and human existence is not
to be understood on the model of things
that is as objects of knowledge okay
so these people are talking about
perception and they get confused with
perception and thinking and mind
and consciousness that's where the
problem comes in okay
okay um here uh
we have another comment okay
mediator one person says what is a
mediator
one that mediates he defines it he looks
up for a definition
a mediating agent in a physical chemical
or biological process
okay yeah again the problem is when you
look up these words
in the ordinary dictionary you're going
to get uh
irrational definitions and that's where
the people you know
you shouldn't look at the dictionaries
you should look at your mind and say
what do we really mean by this word how
do we apply it in science
if you just get worse from ordinary
speech you're going to get them all
wrong because there are no scientific
definitions out there that's the problem
and so you can't just transcribe and say
oh i found this at the dictionary this
is what it means
well does it make sense because if it
doesn't make sense
i don't care where you got it okay you
got to try to make sense and be able to
defend
your definition not just copy anybody
can transcribe
copy you know what have you done a lot
of work
no no mental work the word comes from
media la la la okay is it
light a mediator okay light remember i
i said it the other day like if you're
talking about the rope the
electromagnetic rope that
mediates that serves as a meteor we're
talking about a physical object
but if you're talking about the torsion
moving along the rope then you're not
talking about a physical object so what
is a mediator
well the mediator has to be an object
mediator is a synonym
of thing of entity of object
that's what a mediator is we're talking
about a physical entity
what that which has shape that's a
mediator
okay so you can't say torsion is a
mediator no torsion is the verb
done by the mediator okay that's the way
you're supposed to interpret that okay
another
issue another common question here it is
you can get it up here
they're all far far at the bottom
okay it says by definition nothing
should have no dimension
that is no surface no volume you're
nothing
empty space has no surface
yeah good i like that uh
shape that could be observed no it's got
nothing to do with observing
okay it's got nothing to do with uh
observers with
what people think it's got to do with
definitions
that's that's what it is but he says
it's got no surface nor
no surface or volume okay i would show
here that surface is all that your
nothing has surface has
nothing has surface oh i want to see
this where he got this
and yet it still magically retains
volume
i don't know where he got this notion of
volume volume is a mathematical concept
has nothing to do with what we're
talking about here
but he says you're nothing empty space
is not shapeless after all
oh is it okay it is filled by one
dimensional end of these ropes or
strings
which gives shape to this still
volume-less
empty space i don't know how uh the fact
that
you got ropes inside space gives shape
to space
uh so far we have shapes of the ropes
not
of space but he says nothing by your own
definition of nothing
volume without shape no
space has no volume volume only physical
objects have volume okay and what does
the volume mean it means
expansion okay how much
uh space it takes up because they're
assuming it's
like the fish uh pushing out volume of
water
that it occupies so volume is a
dynamic concept okay and that's why it
has
a unit anything that's got units is
always
a dynamic concept in mathematics
so no space does not have volume okay so
i don't know where he got that volume
thingy
okay another uh common question here it
is
file says uh you can't point to your
shadow
oh he's asking now yeah you can't point
to your shadow i can point to mine all
day long
now you can't point to a shadow because
shadow the word shadow means block
light you can't point to blocked light
because block light there's no physical
stand-alone object called black light
but there's another issue here and
that's where does the shadow start
hey here it is let me show you
graphically what i'm talking about
uh does the shadow stand alone
or does it touch all the way to his feet
where the shadow begin because see when
you have an
object like a ring it's completely all
around
is the ring but a shadow is tied to
whatever object
is blocking the light that's why it's
called blocked light that's what a
shadow is that in other words that's
what
the word shadow means block light so
where does a shadow start is a
standalone object
is it completely does it have shape you
say well it's got shape see i can point
to it no you can't point to it because
i don't know where where it starts as
far as i'm concerned you're pointing to
the man
okay because the shadow comes out of his
feet
if you're going to talk about the shaft
you talk about the man no problem
because
here like i show here you can have the
man without the shadow
and so let's show that okay here you
have the man without a shadow
or you have the shadow only because
you have a light there pointing at him
but we could have no light and uh
and there would be no shadow at all so
we don't need the shadow to have man but
we certainly need the man to have shadow
okay and the question is is that shadow
even if the light is
shown uh uh straight ahead
and the guys you know above uh floating
in space
the shadow extends all the way to his
body
so there so the shadow really is not a
shape in the sense that
uh that it can that you can find out
where it starts
you have no idea where a shadow starts
because it starts
at the foot of the other guy and here
let me show you this guy now in space
to give you an idea here again you know
if you assign a light in space
uh his shadow starts at the man
okay there there is no thing uh
as a shadow that stands alone in the
sense that
you can say it's got shape because the
shape extends all the way to man
you don't have a shape for for black
light
black light goes all the way to the
thing that's blocking the light
so if you can tell me where the shadow
whatever shadow of a tree
of a plant of a rock where it starts
you can tell me that be great show me
that it's
got shape all around meaning
stand alone that it doesn't require
another object
that's the issue with shadow okay
another issue another comment
fellow says uh what says
you haven't given any definition of the
word god can you give a definition of
the word god
well i'm not proposing god so it's the
person who proposes god who's got to
give the definition
he's got to tell you what he means by
god i
whenever i use the word god i usually
refer
to the bible to the old testament
and i use the god that god testified
on his own behalf of who he is he says
it's
i have a face i have eyes i have a nose
i have ears i covered that last week and
so god is made in our image according to
the bible
and that's the god i use so god is not a
definition
i point to god say that's god and it's a
bearded guy you know
uh i guess flying around in space maybe
he's got a magic wand i don't know
uh i don't have to define god because i
don't propose god and second i don't
define god i point to him
okay i use the god of the old testament
okay here's one fella who criticizes
that to some degree he says
uh he says uh bill
thinking that uh the king james version
bible is even close to
an accurate translation of the old
testament is laughable
okay um what we have to
think about here is that you know the
bible has many translations
and the reason they have translated it
so many times
uh is not uh
unknown it's it's we know why they've
translated the bible so many times okay
and why there are new versions every day
of the bible
and here let me show you just uh for the
sake of argument that
in the past they translated the bible
first into latin then they translated
here uh
for the first time into spanish okay
this is the the first
european language in which into which
uh the bible was translated in the year
1280
okay it's known as the iphone cena bible
uh about a hundred years later they
translated the bible into german okay
when's this law uh bible
and so there's been uh different bibles
throughout time
the most famous however are uh the first
one is the casio dododena
bible in spanish this is really you can
say
the most famous bible in spanish the one
used
in the spanish world in england they
came up with a bible similar to that
and a few years later about 60 years
later
the king james version which is the one
i use and the reason i use it is because
if you look at the spanish version and
you look at the english version
they match quite quite well and uh
since then it's been modified a lot of
stuff will have been modified among them
the clobber passages which are in the
process of being
modified even today and for those of you
who
are not familiar with those they have to
do with the gay
uh passages in the bible there's about
seven of them
and they're known as the clobber
passages because they clobber
homosexuality and a lot of people have
problems with that
you know uh out there not only
homosexuals but people who defend them
and they don't like that they're trying
to reinterpret those passages
and so yeah they don't like those
passages what they do they create new
bibles that
modify such passages not only those
there are other passages they're
modifying out there
and so they're modifying these passages
because everybody has
a different interpretation first and
second they don't like
uh some of the things that the bible
says about what they believe
and so that's why they're changing these
bibles and because they're changing them
i stick to what's been around for a
while first of all
and second that matches the spanish
version with the english version which
is the king james
bible they were a little more naive in
those days they just
translated directly there was no i guess
no
need for cheating for reinterpreting
certain things that were straightforward
and today we're doing that why because a
lot of people
don't like what they read in the bible
it destroys their religion they say no
no i like the bible but
let me reinterpret what you what the
what the author
wrote in there and so that's why yeah
i'm going to use the king james version
until i die okay and i did read the
bible three times completely because
it's a book i like
you know i read it when i was young read
it three times
beginning to end all the way and so i
know a little bit what's
inside the bible and yeah believe me uh
they've changed the bible and again they
changed the bible because everybody
wants to interpret
a new religion in fact uh here you can
see
that religion has changed uh here's the
god of the old testament okay this is
just the god of the old testament
okay and he was a god of punishment
there was no
love in there he he just came in there
and he would
[Music]
send plagues and whatever he could
to punish people uh people
saw god's punishment as armies invading
them you know genghis khan and
maybe attila the hun you know they saw
that as
punishment from god they say oh uh god
is going to punish
us because we've been sinning and when
these troops came over and beat them up
or
left some people alive and said you got
to pay tribute you're going to be our
slaves
they said oh god has punished us it was
all punishment
you know they would crucify people burn
them at the stake
they would threaten you with going to
hell it was all bad you look at the old
testaments like that
the new testament is a little different
it's more like what we see today
okay and here it is uh this is the new
testament okay it's
the god of love and diversity that's
what it's all about
it's a smiling god and if you behave
well you have eternal life and it's
going to be a blissful
life because god um pardons everything
he uh he doesn't punish he's a god of
love
and so he accepts everything he wants
brotherhood
and so we have a difference between the
god of the old testament the god of the
new testament i always point that out
among other things that the god of the
old testament is a physical god whereas
the god of the new testament
is an abstract uh god it's a god it's a
concept
and today we've become even more um
abstract with god today again uh you get
people like
deepak chopra uh he says god is
intelligence
and so we've got his intelligence uh how
did intelligence a concept
create the universe and those are the
questions they
they just skip over and say well let's
not talk about that
let's talk about behavior let's talk
about consciousness let's talk about
you know whether you're going to go to
heaven have eternity
life after death or whatever they want
to talk about stuff like that they don't
want to talk about physics how the
universe came into being
uh which is it was the subject of today
and so yeah god has become ever more
abstract and that's why i try to go back
to the
not only to the old testament but also
to the king james version
because that one doesn't lie and that
one is very close to
the one we have in spanish and i can
match them almost identically
the bibles of today you can't do that
anymore everybody's got their own
bible now according to their own
personal religion and they want to shove
that one down your throat
everybody creates a new sect that's what
we have today
with that i'll see you next time around
which is on wednesday
we'll see you there bye-bye